want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn from some of
the best motivation from will
smith
[Music]
skydiving is a really interesting
confront with fear
[Applause]
i gotta stand up you go out
the night before and you you know you
take a drink with your friends
and somebody says yeah we should go
skydiving tomorrow and you go yeah we'll
go skydiving
and everybody goes yeah and you go home
but you by yourself you're like
[Laughter]
right you're like well i mean they was
drunk too
so then that night you're laying in your
bed and you just keep
and you're terrified you keep imagining
over and over again
jumping out of an airplane and you can't
figure out why you would do that
so you get there and then you have the
safety brief
and you're standing there and the guys
will tell you well if the shoot doesn't
open what's going to happen is you're
doing you
well why the hell what could happen
so you get onto the airplane and you're
sitting there and and
you know it's extra because you're
sitting on some dude's lap some stranger
trying to make small talk yeah man so
you do
you you be jumping with people all the
time huh
so you fly and you go up to 14 000 feet
and somebody opens the door
and in that moment you realize you've
never been in a freaking airplane with
the door open
terror terror terror terror
[Music]
and then people start going out of the
airplane
and the guy walks you up to the
end of the thing and you're standing and
your toes
are on the edge and you're looking out
down to death
[Music]
they say on three
[Music]
one
two and he pushes you on two because
people grab on three
and you fall out of the airplane
and in one second you realize that
it's the most blissful experience
of your life you're flying
[Music]
there's zero fear you realize at the
point of
maximum danger is the point of minimum
fear the lesson for me was why were you
scared in your bed the night before what
do you need that fear for
everything up to the stepping out
there's actually no reason to be scared
and then
in that moment all of a sudden where you
should be terrified
is the most blissful experience of your
life
and god placed the best things
in life on the other side of fear so i
do
uh screamed to me the other night hey
will i want to be an actor man i want to
be an actor just like you
you know usually people say stuff to me
like that i'm like yeah man you know you
do is give them an encouraging word
but i was just sitting here thinking and
it dawned on me 99
of people that say stuff like that are
not
willing to do what it takes to make
their dreams come true
the marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven
but nobody wants to die and that's just
real at the center of bringing
any dream into fruition is
self-discipline
you know some something as simple as
food and eating
is not about your your body as much as
it is about your mind it's getting
command
of your mind to be able to choose
actions that are in your own best
interest
every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you and the
world's trying to
hold you down so you gonna kick yourself
in the balls
so you don't stop yourself from getting
what you dream
self-discipline is the center
of all material success you cannot win
the war
against the world if you can't win the
war against your own mind
being prepared for the next
thing is so wildly
critical um i think life in general
is rise and fall everything is rise and
fall
and there's been a couple times in my
life where i got caught
um holding on to
the last wave while it's while it's
dying oh i have a good quote for that
yeah i have a casey neistat quote which
is like that tar i don't think he
probably didn't make this up but tarzan
can't get to the next branch if he
doesn't
yes absolutely that's kind of the same
philosophy yep absolutely and
you've got to be when you're grabbing
that first one and you're holding it
it's going to be there it's fantastic
but you got to
know that you're going to have to let go
at some point because the same thing
that saved your life
if you hang on it'll kill you also if
you want to have more self love and
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free
the links join are in the description
below i look at the world through a lens
of comedy
right so my natural reaction is always
no matter
when something happens and i can't even
help it it's why is that funny
it takes such a desperate obsessive
focus to to excel on a certain on the
level that that
i want to make movies choose actions
that are
in your own best interest every day
we are choosing that's not in our own
best interest you have to be able to be
vulnerable in front of anybody
you know you have to be comfortable
looking silly
you have to be comfortable making
mistakes and you have to break the thing
inside of you that doesn't want people
to see right
because as soon as you allow people to
see all of a sudden you get
access to things that you didn't realize
you had access to
right for example like the thing i used
to do
is when i was in probably 18 or 19 years
old
i got in touch with those blocks the
camera hates
emotional blocks like you put a camera
in somebody's face
and they're uncomfortable about
deliberating emotion it looks fake and
you feel it
you immediately know it's not real right
um
especially look at the size of this
screen and in a shot that whole screen
could be just your
eyes right so it's like you can't
hide discomfort uncertainty so you have
to be
able to get comfortable you know just be
in anything anything that you have to be
for the role you have to be comfortable
being
it
[Applause]
i look at the world through a lens of
comedy
right so my natural reaction is always
no matter when something happens and i
can't even help it
it's why is that funny you know so even
at
a a funeral i can't help
but think why that's funny you know
so it's it's extremely helpful
for me just psychologically that no
matter what's going on i can't keep my
mind from finding jokes
you know so it's a it's a a beautiful
way to stay
joyous and positive don't ever let
somebody tell you
you can't do something
not even me
all right all right
you got a dream you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can't do it
[Applause]
you want something go get it period
something that probably a lot of people
don't know about me
um i don't [ __ ] with the ocean
the ocean is like the ultimate woman she
is
beautiful and she will nourish you
but she will tear you to shreds also
the ocean is my worst fear i don't know
what it is or where it came from but
there's something about not being able
to breathe
i've tried snorkeling before and i was
hyperventilating
my 50th birthday is this year i just
wasn't gonna go
into the back nine of my life
without having attacked my fear of the
ocean
so we're about to scuba dive the great
barrier reef
you know i've never scuba diving scuba
dove
scuba i've never been
scuba divish before so we're taking the
boat ride out
and we go through a storm
on a boat
back to you in the studio sandy
probably 25 years old in my mind and i
knew that i would be here one day
so i'm ready i'm ready
[Music]
wow that's crazy is anybody shooting
this yeah
that's what you call australian booth
how you feeling awesome you ready to go
get it
i'm ready i'm about to go take my spot
look at this this is stupid all right
i'm not going
come on this will be the hardest part of
it
is it okay to punch sharks in the face
you're like back up with your shark ass
back up with your shark ass shuck ass
back up
shock jab shock jack
i got it
[Applause]
the question isn't can you handle the
situation
the question is can you handle your mind
can you manage the thoughts and the
emotions
that are trying to poison your progress
forget managing the situation
manage your mind
[Music]
training your mind to
sit calmly in the eye of the storm
so i was thinking about um love
i was thinking about how difficult it is
for us to find and to to maintain
the love that we all yearn for
and it it kind of dawned on me that i
think a big part of the problem
is that we misdefine love
it's possible that no other one subject
has been
more analyzed talked about and
experienced
by every single person on this planet
than love
and yet we really have no clue what it
is
so me and jada was reflecting
about love you cannot
make a person happy you can make a
person
smile you can make a person feel good
you can make a person laugh
but whether or not a person is happy
is deeply and totally and utterly out of
your control
the thing that we call love the thing
that we're searching for and we're
trying to create
that we call love is actually not love
j krishnamurti talked about the the
concept of
the desire pleasure paradigm
that we think about love in terms of
desire and pleasure
meaning that if you meet my needs then i
love you
if you don't then i don't so that
love becomes transactional
if you do what i want if you meet my
desire and give me pleasure
i love you if you don't meet my desire
and you don't give me pleasure i don't
love you
i think that that in the insatiable
nature of desire
trying to get somebody to fill our cup i
think that that leads to
to anger and it leads to uh frustration
and ultimately it makes us break apart
from people
my daughter willow really taught me a
hard lesson i think that the real
paradigm for love
is gardener flower
so the relationship that a gardener has
with a flower
is the the gardener wants to flower to
be
what the flower is designed to be
not what the gardener wants the flower
to be
you want the flower to bloom and to
blossom and to become what
it wants to be you want it to become
what god
designed it to be you're not demanding
that
it become what you need it to be
for your ego anything other than
all of your gifts wide open giving
and nourishing this flower into their
greatness
is not love the the concept of improving
lives
runs through the center of everything i
do and then i realize
that the the the way to improve lives is
to continually improve yourself right so
with that every every morning when i
when i get out of the bed
you know i i haven't fixed everything
in the world yet so there's always
something to do and uh in this film i
read
an interesting quote um for the
uh siddhartha gautama the buddha he said
that good people have to get out of the
bed
every day and try to empty the ocean
with a ladle right and i thought that
was you know i knew that was profound
and i paused for a second
and i said all right what the hell is a
ladle right
right so that you know i just i touched
it on my ipad it's ladle oh it's like a
big spoon
a big spoon okay it's like a soup spoon
yeah
it's like a soup spoon i was like why
are you a soup spoon so try to empty the
ocean
with a soup spoon you know as the the
mentality of how you
you wake up every day to try to do good
in the world so for me i'm i'm uh i'm
really driven by
continually trying to um
elevate my elevate my mind and elevate
my
spirit and care for my body and um to be
able to love as many people
as effectively as as possible with
this mystery of life that i've been
given i was challenged for that right
like all yourself you're different
your positivity was always challenged
like yeah you always wanted you to
justify
being positive right absolutely yeah no
that was a
that was a uh a difficult
time coming up because it's it's like
i'm from i'm from philly right so during
that time
in philly it was joe frazier and rocky
so
a fist fight was common
yeah uh d used to he called it pug city
he's like pug city he's like
he's like chuck was like damn you can't
go to philly without getting in a fight
so it's like i grew up in that so for me
to
uh it was always difficult for people
you know to say i was soft and i was you
know
my my music was cotton candy and all of
that so i
i always wanted to fight to try to
to to prove myself but the be
fighting yourself to maintain positivity
is the hardest fight you ever gonna have
right and it's like that struggle to
just
stay my course to you know be the person
in the world that
that i wanted to be no matter what
people said and it was uh
uh i started to call it offensive
positivity
right like you know i wasn't gonna be on
defense
with my positivity i was going to be on
offense with it right
i was just uh having a debate with a
friend of mine
and we got stuck on the difference
between fault and responsibility and she
kept talking about how something was
somebody's fault it's somebody's fault
and i was like it really it don't matter
whose fault it is that something is
broken
if it's your responsibility to fix it
for example is it's not somebody's fault
if their father was an abusive alcoholic
but it's for damn sure their
responsibility
to figure out how they're going to deal
with those traumas and try to make a
life out of it
it's not your fault if your partner
cheated and ruined your marriage but it
is for damn
sure your responsibility to figure out
how to take that
pain and how to overcome that and build
a happy life
for yourself fault and responsibility
do not go together it sucks but they
don't when something is somebody's fault
we want them to suffer we want them
punished we want them to to pay
and we want it to be their
responsibility to fix it but
that's that's not how it works
especially when it's your heart
your heart your life your happiness
is your responsibility and your
responsibility
alone as long as we're pointing a finger
and and and stuck in whose fault
something is we're jammed and trapped
into victim mode when you're in victim
mode you're stuck in suffering
the road to power is in taking
responsibility
your heart your life your happiness
is your responsibility and your
responsibility
alone no no we're not just bungee
jumping at a helicopter
we're gonna do it at the grand canyon
and when i was up there and and i jumped
i realized you know it's fun and it's
exciting
and there's something mythological
about confronting death right because as
much as we're laughing and as much as
we're having fun
it really is the emotional confront
with death you know and i'm 50 years old
now
and i'm sort of having the realization
that you you have to be able
to go
[Music]
you have to be able to take that shot
at the thing that you dream you have to
be able to take that
shot at that that love that you want and
that life that you want to build
and it's like you know i was up there
and the guy said to me the only way you
can get
hurt is if you don't get away from the
chopper
right and he said in that moment he said
we're gonna let the courts go and these
cords weigh 200 pounds
right so when we let them go they're
gone
the hesitation is the thing that
really messes up the chance at having
your dreams right
get out of the middle but
the moment of pushing off is
pure freaking terror
[Music]
and then there's the moment of falling
but you're gone so there's really
nothing you can do
and just like life there's nothing to
hold on to
and we're all trying to hold on to
something you're trying to hold on to an
idea or you're trying to
hold on to a person and there's nothing
to hold on to and we got to just get
comfortable
falling knowing there's nothing to hit
right you know and that's the idea it's
like
life is dangerous and the
only way to really enjoy it is jump
and be free you challenge yourself a lot
of times i remember there was even one
rap you was like i did i dare rapper to
write a verse
without a curse so what is it now you
think you've loosened up kind of on this
dance more like you don't mind
yeah you know for me it's um it's
it's much more about authenticity of
duality
right the idea that right and wrong
aren't separate things they're together
right so
something that happens to you is the
best thing and the worst thing that
happens to you you can't
you can't separate them like they go
together
everything has it's yin and it's yang
and you
can't get around it so the idea that my
grandmother
teaching me um about profanity
during that time was what worked to help
elevate
my um career and it helped elevate my
experiences
but it's not necessarily right
to not curse you you curse
when it's the right thing not
gratuitously not true
you you know it's like when it makes
your point
like telling telling somebody to shut
the [ __ ] up at the right time
is the right thing you scared me right
you know what i mean so it's like um
given
myself rather than specific
hard and fast rules and paradigms now
i'm trying to
feel the universe and feel the moments
and feel the opportunities
for what is right for me in this moment
in the world i i'm always connecting to
an idea i'm always asked why am i making
this
what why so i'm putting this out in the
world
why so with with concussion dr bennett
omalu was deeply
connected to tell the truth and he said
that
truth doesn't have a side and that's
what he kept saying i thought that was
such a powerful
idea that they're you know whose side
are you on are you a republican or a
democrat i'm
i'm just i'm trying to tell the truth
true the truth doesn't
have a side right i gotten probably two
weeks into
my uh preparation for the film and
uh my father was diagnosed with cancer
you know
and that was another thing that my
father taught me he was he was joking
all the way up to the end like laughing
you have to be able to laugh at
everything
and for me the beautiful part is
that that's my natural um
color on the spectrum i naturally go to
comedy
you know and when when when i'm looking
at something i'm always trying to find
why that's funny
and you know it's been really really
helpful
in in this experience and and you know
even just
uh this point in my life keep remember
to laugh remember to laugh
and and spend time with people that make
you laugh
like that is hugely important laugh and
connect
yes absolutely those are good messages
yeah
thank you very much wait no what are you
doing yeah
turns out you have somewhere to be oh oh
really i got oh but this is
i'm i'm enjoying i know you you know
[Applause]
i love this um but apparently you have
to go like
pay some bills i gotta pay some bills
okay well thank thank you guys very much
is uh this this has been spectacular i
know it's crazy but you know what i know
we have a little piece of a movie for
you we're going to show you a featurette
oh we got a feature wreck we have a
featurette um
you've probably seen it already i
probably seen it yeah oh i get to go
okay
[Applause]
but you'll be back right
i have to show up at work with the right
attitude and with the positive
energy and uh i actually
had a t-shirt made that said positive
energy
is a part of your job description right
so
the the idea that um i want to show up
with the right energy i want to show up
you know we're all here
you know even now we're all here we're
trying to feed our families we're
we're trying to have a good time we're
trying you know
this is an important uh part of our
lives our time
is all that we have so to me it's hugely
important
to deliver positive energy in a way
because it's vibrant so if
i come with positive energy then someone
else is going to pick up on the positive
energy and you're going to take it home
to your families and
you know so for me it's just hugely
important to approach everything
and everybody at every turn with the the
the most positive loving kindness
that i can generate you told the famous
story about how you kind of backed into
acting fresh prince of bel-air yeah and
the next thing you know you start making
these movies and i forget that bad boys
actually came before independence day
right yeah
yeah independence day just was like one
of the biggest of all time like
what was that transition like for you
yeah real actor and like the biggest
actor in the game
no it was um that was like the first
real um goal like that
in terms of setting goals i was like i
want to be the biggest movie star in the
world
right and every up until that point
everything was
like it was fun and it was happening and
we were creating in jeff's mom's
basement and
it was successful but that was like when
i moved into acting
that was the first time i started uh
applying
uh skill to my
my talents right and you know i always
look i look at skill and talent
separately like p you're born with
talent you know it's like there's
certain things that you just do
naturally you were gifted with a talent
and
you have it um but skill is
acquired through discipline
and you know i've never seen myself as
particularly talented where i excel is
i'm willing to die in the process of
acquiring skill
like it's you know when i put my
obsessive mind on something i'm just not
yeah right
exactly exactly yes and i cannot work
you i said you also have ridiculous and
sickening work
sickening work epic exactly it's like
you know so for me
to be a movie star was the first thing
that i ever really wanted like that and
set my eyes he was like
what's the vegas stallone all of them i
was like
i was like you know because when i when
i looked
i always felt like there weren't a lot
of
people i saw do things that i felt like
i couldn't do
right when i when i look at people and i
see things um
i don't i don't feel like i can't
whether or not i will
is something different but i don't ever
feel like i can it's funny i learned a
really valuable lesson in this right
because the
um the the network
wanted to do one more season of
the fresh prince and i remember
i was considering i was going to do one
more season
of the fresh prince and we had we've
done an episode of something with
john amos and john amos came to me said
hey man listen
he's like don't overstay your welcome
on on tv he was like you're doing
great stuff he's like you do not want to
get canceled in the middle of a season
it's like go out on your terms the way
that you want to go out be able to say
goodbye
to your fans don't get caught okay yeah
that's good advice
and so this was the sixth season and i
had an
opportunity to do one more season but i
was feeling like
the quality wasn't necessarily
going to stay up and i decided to to
end the show in the in the sixth season
can you talk about
advice that you're happy you didn't take
at some point in your careers
oh man yeah this one yeah
sorry mom
um one of the most critical
uh for me and and um
you know it was uh it was 1986
um and girls ain't nothing but trouble
came out in in june so i had a i had a
record out
a month before i graduated from high
school
right so first song it was at pretty
much just
in philly and and you know dc
jersey it hadn't expanded yet um
but it was time for me to start applying
to college
and um and you know my mother is a
serious uh you know educational
disciplinarian it's like education was
everything for her
and she could tell that i was kind of
feeling like maybe i didn't want to go
to college
and you know she told me that you know
if i didn't go
to college that i was throwing my life
away
and and it's like i i understood what
she was saying but that that just wasn't
true for me
you know that wasn't true for me at the
time and i wanted to take a shot at my
art i wanted to take a shot at the music
and you know so uh my father
convinced my mother that i would have a
year they would give me a year
where i would be able to pursue the the
music
and then if in a year i hadn't made
anything happen
that that i would go back to to college
um
and in that year uh we were nominated
and we won the the first grammy ever
given
i never did anything for money
um my experience has been when people do
things for money
you make bad choices find what you love
and then you'll learn how to make money
doing
what you love here when i changed
careers
i was never changing to something for
money i was changing to something i
loved more right and that to me that's
really the only way to keep the passion
if you have two choices
one is
and you can make more money bowling but
you love playing the piano more
you got to play the piano it's like
you'll tear yourself apart if you're not
doing the thing that you love most in
life
and you know what it is right now right
now there's something that you
love more than everything i've never
i've never really thought about age and
felt it that way but like last year when
i turned 50 it was like
it's a five in front of it like
the the five like 40 was cool 30 was
cool like 50 was like
whoa man we need to jump out a
helicopter or something
you know it really it uh it hit me a
little bit but the the
accepting uh being older and even for
gemini man
a lot of those things came up and you're
thinking about previous life and you
think about
the the karma of the mistakes you've
made and
what would you not do you know if you if
you had known and all of those things
came up but it but uh
i've solved the problem i'm i am i am
having
an absolute ball with my life right now
for me
is laughing is the elixir
you know and that was another thing that
my father taught me he was
he was joking all the way up to the end
like
laughing you have to be able to laugh
at everything and for me the beautiful
part is that that's my natural
um uh color on the spectrum i
naturally go to comedy you know and when
when
when i'm looking at something i'm always
trying to find why that's funny
taking responsibility accepting
responsibility
is not an admission of guilt
you're not you're not admitting that
you're
at fault taking responsibility is a
recognition
of the power that you seize when you
stop
blaming people it's not like you're
letting somebody who wronged you off the
hook
like taking responsibility is an act of
emotional self-defense
taking responsibility is taking your
power back
the thing is um and you know when i
when i started i had you know all these
grand ambitions of what i wanted to be
and what i wanted to do
and you know i want to be the biggest
movie star in the world um so i studied
that and i worked out and i got my body
crazy and i did you know
just got my head around um doing
everything i could do
to be the biggest movie star in the
world you know
and then i had a taste of that and i
realized that even though i had achieved
all those things
on the inside i was still that same
insecure little boy
that was trying to prove something you
know to
to you know girls that had cheated and
to my father
and all of that and that you can't
achieve your way
out of your you know childhood
wounds and traumas you can't fake it you
can't fake it right so then i made the
shift
and what i realized is that the only
sustainable mission
um throughout your whole uh existence is
to improve lives
and as soon as i made the shift in my
mind from trying to be big and trying to
have money and trying to be
popular to making sure that i improved
lives
every step of the way on this earth then
all of a sudden
i started experiencing healing you know
and alfonso was one of those people that
was right there with me
making that transition from product and
winning
to love and people always always a
pleasure to talk to you
this is such a different original story
so what was your first thought when you
got the script
uh i love the title first of all the
collateral beauty you know the idea that
uh no matter how difficult a
circumstance is
uh if you stay conscious and aware
you'll be able to see something
beautiful in it
i thought that was beautiful um and then
the idea of love
time and death you know i
just you know the way that they played
out in the screenplay i thought alan
loeb
wrote a uh just a gorgeous script
yeah and a very relatable story to all
audiences all over the world
as a parent i'm sure finding uh you know
understanding
his dark place is not difficult because
it's such an intolerable idea absolutely
but what helped you understand his way
back his reconnection
you know it was it's um i've i've
always been um the the type of person
who
uh thought of i thought of myself as
resilient
you know that i could always make my way
back being stuck in the past is a
it makes it extremely difficult to to
find your way
out and future thinking for me has
always been the way to get over
difficult times to be able to look over
the darkness to
a potential time of light
rarely do i look backwards i'm always uh
looking forward so both your kids are in
showbiz too
is that worrying for you or no you know
not
it's you know to me showbiz
is not separated from
the rules of the universe right so
whether you're in show business
or you know you're selling cars
or you're farming you know you're not
you're not separate from the laws of the
universe and
all of the rules are the same everywhere
so for you know for from
my children the most important thing is
that they be encouraged to
fully and thoroughly be themselves
no matter what and when you when you
have yourself and you're thorough and
confident in who you
are you can survive anywhere i love this
one
fail early fail often fail forward
um you know it's always a little bit
frustrating to me when people have a
negative relationship with failure
failure is a massive part of being able
to be
successful you have to get comfortable
with failure yeah you have to actually
seek failure failure is where all of the
lessons are
you know when you go to the gym and you
work out you're actually
seeking failure you want to take your
muscles to the point
where you get to failure because that's
where the the adaptation is that's where
growth is successful people fail
a lot they fail a whole lot more than
they succeed but they extract the
lessons
from the failure and they use that the
the energy
and they use the wisdom to come around
to the next phase
of success you got to take a shot you
have to live
at the edge of your capabilities you got
to live
where you're almost certain you're going
to fail
that's the reason for practice practice
is controlled
failure you're getting to your limit
getting to your limit getting to your
limit
you can't lift that you can't do that
you until you get to the point that all
of a sudden
your body makes the adjustment and then
you can do it
failure uh actually helps you
to recognize the areas where you need to
evolve
so fail early fail often
fell forward i think it was 94 or
something like that
they were open to planet hollywood i
found myself in a room with arnold
schwarzenegger bruce willis
and sly and i was like oh my god i got
these three guys in the room
and i was like okay i want to be
the biggest movie star in the world and
i need you guys to tell me how to do it
and arnold schwarzenegger he said
he said if your movie is only big in
america
it doesn't matter you'll be a movie star
only when you're a movie star in every
country in the world you have to travel
you have to go you have to meet the
people thanks for the tip facts
son facts that became the way that i
started looking at movies i wanted to be
in every country in the world
in that part of my career i refused
to do anything that wasn't in
the best interest of the goal i had set
for myself and it was probably a 12-year
period of my life where i didn't take a
drink
i didn't have a drink where i didn't go
out on weekends that i was
so set on my goal it created a
serious circle of protection
and and elevation because i refused to
do
anything that wasn't in my best interest
it's hugely important that if you have a
dream
that you have to dedicate your life to
it and
you're every hour of every day has to be
dedicated to bringing into fruition the
things that
you dream about i just saw this uh
roomie quote
that i love set your life on fire
and seek those who fan your flames
the philly translation of that is don't
be hanging with no jank ass
jokers that don't help you shine the
prerequisite for spending time
with any person is that they nourish
and inspire you they feed your flame
look at your last
five text messages are those people
feeding your flames or dousing your fire
put your phone down for just a second
and
look around look to the people around
you
are those people throwing logs on your
fire
or are they pissing on it the people
that you
spend time with are gonna make or break
your dreams
everybody don't deserve to be around you
you got to defend your light
with your life so who are the people in
your life
that are fanning your flames it's like
everybody
was sitting at home looking at their
devices right
when what felt like a new atrocity to
some people
but was happening over and over again
for african americans and for this to
happen in
this time for the whole world to
see what we've been saying
for hundreds of years yes my grandmother
taught me to
try to be thankful for these times and
these opportunities
to try to be thankful for your pain you
know and
we are in a circumstance that we've
never been before
the entire globe has stood up
and said to the african-american
people we see you and we hear you
how can we help we've never been there
before
you you know for me it comes down to
you know after you get beyond the rage
rages
is justified under oppression
it also can be really dangerous you got
to be careful not to be consumed by your
own rage yeah you know and that's
something that i've worked
really hard on and what i loved about
the peaceful protest
it's like peaceful protests put up a
mirror
to the demonic imagery of your oppressor
and the more still you are in your
peaceful protest the more
clear the mirror is
to the oppressor for the world to see
and for them to see
themselves you know so i was really
encouraged by
how powerfully this generation
was able to hold that mirror you know i
think
my dreams over the past you know couple
of decades
have been like you know physical dreams
i wanted to
accomplish things you know i wanted to
be the biggest movie star in the world
um and yeah you know so it was all
success oriented and i think now
um if you look at it away like going up
the
mountain i was acquiring right and i
guess as i come down on the other side
now i want to give it away
right so sort of the the the
dreams that i have is i i want to be
valuable
like i want to be valuable to humanity
i want to you know i haven't totally
found my calling as of yet but i want my
life to be
of value to as many people and in as
many ways
as possible nervous is great
it means you're outside your comfort
zone
but growth happens did you cut your hair
that looks nice man besides you never
really needed permission to take matters
into your own hands
that's jayden on his brand new drum set
or dive head first into the unknown
or being courageous enough to try
something new
and consistent enough to stick to it for
years even when it knocks you down
or take challenges on way bigger than
yourself this is our first bottle just
water
you feel good about it guys this is
amazing you've always had an
interesting sense of self-expression
but you take jabs like a champ and deal
dealing back
with effortless classes i have a gut now
right
be honest we never really understood
your thing with bugs though
seeing you roll around on the ground was
a lot cuter
when you were a baby
you were nervous shoot i was nervous
[Applause]
but we did the damn thing out there
when i started in in entertainment
um the lack of tech
was a massive creative hindrance
right it was um
you could have an idea and it literally
could take you a month
before you could get the resources
together
to get the idea out of your mind onto
something you could listen to
okay right with music um and
with film it was impossible if you had
if you had images in your mind
you know and with a super 8
camera to try to shoot something and
then try to sync some it was
literally impossible so two things
happened with that so with
what one with rap music what happened
was
only the best of the best got through
right so 1986 the summer that
me and jeff released our first album
if i named all the rappers you would
know who they were because you you
jazzy jeff and fresh friends heavy d
eric beer rock
public enemy it's like you did you
couldn't get through yeah so then what
happens with technology as soon as
technology gets democratized then
everybody can do it
and now more things get out and there's
a lesser quality to the things that
make it to to the world so i would say
uh technology is an absolute um
necessity to advance human imagination
you differentiate though between talent
and hard work absolutely
i've never really viewed myself as
particularly talented i view myself as
you know slightly above average in
talent
where i excel is ridiculous sickening
work ethic
you know while the other guy's sleeping
i'm working while the other guy's eating
i'm working while the other guy's making
love
well i mean i'm making love too but i'm
working really hard at it
so when the phone rings you have an
alarm goes off since denzel washington
right now is hooking up
you got to go ahead right now right you
know
for me man it's it's like the the
separation of talent
and skill is one of the the the greatest
misunderstood concepts for people who
are trying to excel who have dreams that
want to do things
talent you have naturally skill is only
developed
by hours and hours and hours of beating
on your craft
and you know for me it's i feel like i
have a relationship with the audience
they agree
that they're going to go in droves and i
agree that every time they go it's going
to be better
than the last time so i think that's
part of the the the relationship and i'm
going to hold up my part as long as they
keep holding up there
i think that the important thing is
there there's there's one relationship
that you have to maintain and that's the
one with you
right and it's like if if you're not
loving you if you're not taking care of
you
everything and everybody is second to
you taking care of you
can you come back tomorrow
you need to let that breathe
and when when you have bad relationships
and and when things go wrong which they
which they always will
it's like you know me and jay to be
going at it me and me and my kids
you know there's heavy debates around
things a lot but
first and foremost when you are steady
and calm
in yourself it makes it easier to manage
the insanity that other people
are going to bring to you because like
as soon as somebody else is off the hook
if you respond to off the hook with off
the hook the relationship's done
yeah you know so it's like taking taking
care of you
centering yourself the airline's got it
right put your mask on first
before attempting to assist others okay
okay you had great success obviously at
the box office but you know you did your
thing on a small screen too
show called the fresh prince yeah man it
was like i was ridiculous quincy just
he knows how to put stuff together and i
don't
uh relentlessly on me
to elevate like james avery wouldn't
give
me a damn inch like
everything i said everything i did
for james avery was like nope not good
enough
you know he was like if you you have
this position
look where you are look what you are
blessed with it was like i'm sorry but
i'm not accepting anything
other than absolute
uh committed perfection from you and at
that time i was bawling you know
and james avery wouldn't give me nothing
and it's like he was
he was the model for me of an
actor you know so the craft it's like
james avery was no like he was
so uh like serious and like i would look
at him
and and he just had that acting power
that i wanted to have
right
[Music]
my parents drove us across country
to we were going to california for a
family reunion
so we drove to the grand canyon
and we got there and i like
i remember having a deeply meaningful
experience of how beautiful it was but i
was terrified to walk up to the edge
and all my brothers and sisters and my
whole family walked up to the edge
and i stayed back you know just scared
to to take in beauty
if you're scared you're not going to
take the chances that you need to take
to to realize your dreams and that was
the thing for me i don't mind being
scared
but i'm still going to do it
life is hard right like yeah
you might get hurt it's like
you know you're you your heart might get
broken
you know it's like you might lose your
job but
you still got to commit you know
you gotta commit right you know what i
mean and it's like
you know you meet somebody and you hey
you know you like her and
she likes you and you're hesitating
don't hesitate
go commit you got to commit you know
you might get hurt you might lose
something but it's like
you can't experience the the joy
that is intended for you in life if you
don't
go i think what makes a great mc is the
same thing that makes a great father
makes a great husband makes a great
politician makes a great human being
and it is your commitment to your
personal
evolution your personal growth for the
purpose
of assisting others like um
you know i'm working on this record now
called uh um
it's called the mountaintop and the the
idea is i've been to the mountaintop
right and it's like i'm going to do
reports from the summit
right i've been to the top of money i've
i've had all the sex that i've ever
wanted
i've had all of the adulation and
and adoration and i've been to the top
of all of those material world mountains
and nothing makes you
happy other than being useful to others
that's it it's the only thing that ever
will satisfy
that thing is that what you are is
useful
one of the favorite things i love to do
is create uh
awe-inspiring experiences that cultivate
growth that cultivate wisdom
that you know elevate uh understanding
right
so when i go somewhere with my kids um i
always wanna push them
i just want to push the envelope
slightly and yeah as you say you get out
of that comfort zone just a little bit
that's where your growth space
is so watching somebody uh experience
wonder and all
and grow that's i just love to do
however we can build that
so me and jada was reflecting
about love and i asked her i said what
did she think was
you know one of the biggest revelations
that she had had about love
she said that you cannot
make a person happy
and i thought that was a real deep idea
you can make a person smile you can make
a person
feel good you can make a person laugh
but
whether or not a person is happy is
deeply and totally and utterly out of
your control
i remember day um
i retired i literally said to jada
that's it i retire i retire
from trying to make you happy i need you
to go make yourself happy and just prove
to me
that it's even possible and after we
cracked the hell up
um we started talking about we came into
this false romantic
concept that somehow when we got
married that we would become one and
what we realized
is that we were two completely separate
people
on two completely separate individual
journeys
and that we were choosing to walk our
separate
journeys together but her happiness
was her responsibility and my happiness
was my responsibility and we decided
that we were going to
find our individual uh
internal private separate joy
and then we were going to present
ourselves to the relationship and to
each other already happy
not coming to each other uh begging with
our empty cups out
uh demanding that she fill my cups in
the cup and demanding that she meet my
needs
it's unfair and it is it's kind of
unrealistic
and can be destructive
to place the responsibility for your
happiness
on anybody other than yourself
difference
between depression and joy
right and i think
it's purpose right it's like
when you wake up in the morning and
your life means something to somebody
other than you
that you have a purpose if you don't go
do the things that you're going to do
people's lives will suffer
and i think that that kind of purpose
that like to live
in service not to you but to live in
service to
humanity to live in service to your
family to live in service to your church
to your city to your country to the
world
living in service is that i uh
i feel like that is the purest form
of joy greatness is not this
um wonderful esoteric elusive
uh god like feature
that only the special among us
uh will ever taste you know it's
something that truly exists
in all of us it's very simple
this is what i believe and
i'm willing to die for it yeah period
it's that simple i know who i am i don't
know what i believe i know who i am i
know who whatever
i need to know that's all i need to know
so from there
you do what you need to do yeah you know
and i think what happens is
we make the situation more complex than
it has been because we're looking for
complexity it's got to be something
complex to understand
right can't be that easy the separation
of talent
and skill is one of the the the greatest
misunderstood concepts for people who
are trying to excel who have dreams they
want to do things
talent you have naturally skill is only
developed
by hours and hours and hours of beating
on your crap
there's no easy way around it no matter
how talented
you are your talent is going to fail you
if you're not skilled
you know if you don't study if you don't
work uh really hard and dedicate
yourself to being better
every single day you'll never be able to
communicate
with with people rejection is everywhere
you know we all deal with the the
you don't anymore yeah me
worst of all the worst of all you know i
think the the idea
of rejection is
relative i mean if you you take a you
know a kid
in a small town and
somebody posts something negative about
them
and all of their friends laugh you know
that's the worst rejection a human being
can experience
it's not you know for that kid it's not
any
less than for my kids who read it on a
comment page
you know it's it's emotionally it's it's
the same my kids grew up
in this world so they're much more
acclimated
to the difficulties of this world but it
doesn't make it
uh emotionally um uh
more difficult or more painful than for
any other child who has to deal with it
you're like the prince but now you're
the king of instagram i know right now
so it's like how come you've embraced
social media in this way like because
for the longest you know you have this
mystique behind you
well in you know when i when i started
the
the the only way to be a movie star
was through uh distance
and mystery and mystique right that was
the
the the way is that you know yeah you
could see me on july 4th in the movie
theater
or you're not gonna see me right so that
was the way
keeping that distance was how you
maintained
uh star power and in the last five years
that shifted uh much more to
a friendship model like people support
um artists that they feel like they know
thoroughly that they're friends right so
that the social media
the the daily interaction is much more
like a family
friendship kind of interaction that is
an audience demand
for uh for
you know their loyalty but is there such
thing as
revealing too much um not in this world
um too much that that's it's personal
you know like it's
it's what can you handle you know i
think one of the major
um one of the the beautiful parts of
social media that i think is a beautiful
evolutionary thing is that social media
demands
uh authenticity right so social media
pushes you
more and more into having to
reveal what's true and because
if you don't you know tmz is going to
right yeah
you know so it's um you know it's a
beautiful thing i'm and
i'm actually enjoying the push right
nobody's happy who doesn't get to beat
himself
right so the the the eyes and ears of
the world are starting to demand
more and more authenticity where you
gotta say what's true for you
and live or die by what that is so i'm
enjoying
the uh the social demand for
authenticity i'm coming into a space how
have you maintained your authenticity
because i mean you come from philly
you've
gone through everything like your
journey's been crazy like how have you
maintained that
um you know what's really interesting is
it's like
the the idea i i i haven't maintained
my authenticity per se i've maintained
my character right i've maintained
um my beliefs
character in two senses have maintained
my character of will smith
and i've maintained my personal
character of
what i believe in so but in terms of
authenticity um
the character will smith
signs every autograph and is always
happy and wants to see
the fans and is always in a good mood
and that's actually not often
authentic right i actually i do want to
slap some
somebody you know every once in a while
so in terms of
authenticity i i have successfully
maintained
positivity and now i'm working
more to maintain authenticity i'm
granting myself
the freedom to not give when i don't
give up
yeah right and now i'm working into a
space
of much more uh authenticity i'm
motivated
by fear fear you know
uh fear of what fear of fear
i hate being scared to do something
yeah i hate that feeling of
the feeling that i had before i had a
meeting with quincy jones because it was
really
uh quincy jones and a guy named benny
medina oh i know
and jeff [ __ ] came with the idea for
the fresh prince of bel-air
and i hated being scared
you know like that i didn't want to
even take the meeting there were there
were opportunities during
uh when i first my first year as a
rapper
bill cosby and and the people on the
cosby show had seen
my music video and called me to be a
character
to come right and try out for the cosby
show and
just every time it was set up for some
reason
i couldn't make it the fear of fear the
fear i hated i just hated that
being scared to do something and i think
what developed
uh in my in my early days was the
the attitude that i started attacking
things
that i was scared you a better man than
me
you happy now you're gonna tell will
or not i'm not going to do your dirty
work for you
fine uh i'll call them from the road
yeah then why don't you do that yeah
i'll do that
daddy out what's up
well i'm glad you're here
um some business came up i got a handle
so we're gonna have to put uh our trip
on hold
you understand yeah yeah
that's that's cool just for a couple
weeks i understand get it
maybe a little longer yeah whatever
whatever
look i'll i'll call you next week and
we'll iron out the details
okay yeah yeah
it was great seeing you son
you too lou
yeah yeah um
i'm sorry will you know what actually
this works out better for me you know as
slim as the summer come to class wearing
next to nothing you know
well it's all right to be angry hey why
should i be mad
i'm saying at least he said goodbye this
time i just wish i hadn't
wasted my money buying this stupid
present
i'm sorry you know if there was
something that i hey you know what you
ain't going to do no
nothing phil you know ain't like i'm
still five years old you know
ain't like i'm gonna be sitting up every
night asking my mom when's daddy coming
home you know
who needs him hey he wasn't there to
teach me how to shoot my first basket
but i learned didn't i hey i got pretty
damn good at the two didn't uncle phil
got through my first date without him
right i learned how to drive
i learned how to shave i learned how to
fight without him i had 14
great birthdays without him he never
even sent me a damn car
die out with him
i need him then and i don't need him now
now you know what uncle phil
i'ma get through college without him i'm
gonna get a great job without him i'mma
marry me a beautiful honey and i'm
having a whole bunch of kids i'll be a
better father than he ever was and i
sure as hell don't need him for that
because ain't a damn thing he could ever
teach me
about how to love my kids
how come you don't want me man
do
i realized that when to have the level
of success
that i want to have it's difficult to
spread it out
and do multiple things you know it's in
order to
to be world-class and i've made a
decision i want to be
world-class and it just it takes such
a desperate obsessive focus
to to excel on a certain on the level
that that
i want to make movies you know i was a
star wars when i was young i sat in a
movie theater and watched star wars and
i just couldn't believe
that that movie made me feel like that
just floored
and just stunned by the creativity and
just i'm realizing that in order
to move people in that way in order to
touch people in that way
you really got to focus with all of your
fiber and all of your heart and all your
creativity
as a child my parents always told me you
could be whatever you want to be you
could do whatever you want to do
and you know that that office that
position
the highest office on the face of the
earth
it was something i heard my parents
saying it but i didn't totally believe
it yet i went out in the world and i
carried myself and i held my head high
and i stood there and i looked people in
their eyes and i talked to people
as if i was deserving of everything that
this planet has to offer
i just i really want to say to to
children out there
and to to people who are watching
confucius said one time
he who says he can and he who says he
can't are both usually right
so i want to stand here before you and
as i hold this award
i want to give love to my wife and i
want you to keep in your heart just know
that you can
know that you can the greatest thing in
my in
my career has been the
constant commitment to putting something
in the world of value
not putting something in the world that
makes me look hot
you know yeah so i think as long as you
can stay
focused on delivering your art and
delivering yourself and delivering your
energy
and delivering your ideas for the world
to be
better you know i've always been really
product oriented you know it's like i
want to win
when i do something i want to win i want
it to be number one
and i want to smash it and i had a
period
you know i have a daughter and i was of
a 15 year old daughter and she really
she got me and shifted uh my
focus from product to people it took a
couple of years but as soon as i got
knocked off of product and started
shifting to people the whole world
opened up for me again and acting opened
up in a whole
new way to not go into day one of a
movie
trying to figure out what everybody has
to do so we win
versus opening up and every person is a
new
uh it's a whole new world meaning the
characters you play or the people you
work with
both absolutely you know generally when
i went into
a product when i went into a meeting
with a director
my focus was can this guy win can this
girl win
and that it was a it was a you know it
was a pathology that got broken
for me a couple of years ago and then
releasing that and just wanting to
connect with people and wanting to grow
and wanting to get new ideas
and have new experiences that don't
have to have uh an outcome
it just opened up a whole new world for
me and i fell in love and then i
couldn't
imagine what else i could do in acting
that could add so much to my life do you
get nervous
or afraid um i i live
in complete terror like you know
everything for me about this business
and
uh you know about what i've been trying
to build and what i've been
trying to do with my life keeps me in
terror i'm i am
deeply motivated by fear
i'm surprised you say you you live in
fear how do you
deal with that do you turn to somebody
for advice do you
meditate what how do you get over that
you know i'm trying to
to develop a more realistic perspective
of what this business is yeah i told my
mother this
the the other day she thought it was
hilarious i said
when i was 15 years old my first
girlfriend cheated on me
oh and i remember making a decision that
nobody
would ever cheat on me again and the way
i was going to do that is by
being the biggest actor on earth huh
right so is there's there's been this
weird psychology that i've always felt
like if my movies are number one my life
is going to work out great
huh you know and like this oh that's
just
bright goes out to 190 countries
um hundreds of millions of people see it
but it's
not in theaters so for two artists what
is the unique satisfaction of this
you know so for me it's really
experimental
what i learned uh when independence day
came out so i was i had been doing the
fresh prince
and that friday before independence day
came out
everybody will will will that monday
was the first time that anybody ever
called me mr smith
right so there's something about that
big
screen that massive blockbuster that
does
something inside of people emotionally
so i'm curious as to see because netflix
is doing
all of the other stuff absolutely you
know it's exactly
the same production process the
promotion
everything is exactly the same you would
do for a gigantic blockbuster
and the question is will
the emotional resonance the sort of
nostalgic residue a year two years three
years from now
still be there with people not
experiencing it in the overwhelming
fashion of the
cinema so you're just this is an
experiment and we'll see how it works
we'll see how it goes yeah but it's
definitely the future you know i got the
call from ridley and he said uh
he said i've got a gift for you and uh
he he sent me a concussion and
uh you know i read it immediately and
i remember thinking uh this ain't no
damn gift
i was like i'm a football dad yeah so
you know
for for me it was a beautiful
uh screenplay but it opened up a huge
conflict for me did you know about about
what had happened before did you know
the story
a little bit vaguely okay really vaguely
i i knew uh you know my son played
football for
for four years um and during that time i
had never heard
uh about the the concussion issue okay
at all
okay so you know it was part of what
really uh
inspired me and made me want to to to
do the the film forced me to to have to
to do the film is because as a parent i
had no
idea right i had no idea that there was
a
an issue with repetitive head trauma
right right in in
football you know so it was a uh it was
a
quite quite a revelation your personal
confrontation with death
made me see the value of time and the
fact that the
only elixir is love you know so
the the the time that you spend has got
to be
in preparing yourself and giving and
receiving
uh the most amount of love you can my
mission is to improve lives
so i want to do things that put
positivity
and positive energy and love
into the world so i'm going to put on
this uh orc mask
because i can't walk the floor at comic
con as
me i'm out in the middle with everybody
i think i'm with people all right so
now i feel sorry for joel
only all these things but if we go out
in public
i'm gonna kill somebody so let's go
and i never get to do this this is gonna
be great i'm gonna get to walk around
[Music]
it's hard to see and it's hard to
breathe
but i'm a soldier so i don't need
neither one of them thing
i'm gonna bark i'm gonna park
come
hey
finding your purpose like that's a
that's a that's a big one just keep
trying stuff
just keep trying you got to keep keep
going and uh and in terms of finding
purpose it was helpful for me to realize
that just because everybody in philly
believed you know one thing and one set
of ideas and everybody in philly
was in a certain paradigm as soon as i
got
out of the city and out of the country i
realized there were people that didn't
give a damn
about stuff that was the most important
thing in the world try
experiment meet travel that was a big
part for me and that's a lot of what
you're going to see on my youtube
channel too like travel
is huge i went to
a catholic school up to
8th grade with uh
all white kids and probably two or three
black kids
but you know predominantly white school
and then
i went to my neighborhood high school in
ninth grade that was 99
black kids um so the first day
that i walk in to ninth grade
i walked into the lunchroom and you know
it's like 500 kids
and for to this day i don't know why i
did this
i'm sure it was because i was i was
nervous
and you you know i got i have a thing
with fear i don't like being scared
so i'm sure i was i walked in uh i
looked around
and i said excuse me can i have your
attention can i have your attention
please
he's here he's here right now thank you
thank you people was kind of looking and
there was this one dude and he was
sitting there
and he looked up to me he said man don't
nobody give that you here
right and i said hey just give me 10
minutes
your girl gonna care right and he was
like
all right and you got to watch that knot
that nod is not a good nod he was like
and i was like okay so i went so i'm
walking up the steps we're out of the
lunchroom and i forgot about it
so we're going and i'm walking up the
steps and he had taken one of those
combination locks
and he put the lock in the palm of his
hand and put his put the uh
the loop around his knuckle and he was
holding the lock in his hand
and as i was walking up the steps he
cracked me in the side of my head
with the lock and i went down i was out
i don't remember nothing i still got the
lump on my head
you can't see it cause i got my hair but
i still like there's still a lump
so i remember i fell down i hit my mouth
on the steps
all of that stuff you know so i went up
so i'm in the principal's office all of
that the police come
and i got the ice on my lips and i'm i'm
sitting
in the principal's office and my father
comes in
he sees me and you know i'm telling the
story now the police are there
and i remember i saw this kid
they put him in handcuffs and
took him out of the school and i'm
looking sitting in the principal's
office and i'm watching the police take
him out and put him in the back of a
police car
and i just couldn't believe it had
escalated to a kid being removed from
from school and
i was laying in my bed that night
and i was just feeling like shh
and i had the recognition that i had
caused this kid to
throw his life away right
and he was kicked out of school and i
never knew what what happened to him but
i
i have a sense that it didn't go well
beyond there and i felt a
deep sense of
regret and a deep sense that i had
caused
an emotion in a person that made them do
that
and that that feeling of regret
turned into a sort of a fear
of how much power i had and i was like
everything i say and do has that kind of
effect
on other human beings and in that moment
i decided that i would never walk into a
room
and do anything other than inspire and
uplift and enlighten people and help
people
to be the greater versions
of themselves and i would never do
anything
that would cause people to
to rile up the darkest dirtiest
parts of people i only wanted to enliven
and enlighten
and inspire and i remember laying in my
bed
that night and i made that promise to
myself and i made that promise
to god and it's something that has
completely
shaped how i approach people how i
approach moments
how i walk into rooms how i deal with
every human being
on this earth all right here's what's
going to happen twitch is going to ask
us each to name three things
of uh three types of like cars or
something and we'll have five seconds to
name three things and then
hit that to see how much time is left on
the clock okay all right
if you do it you get a point if time
runs out you get no points at all five
seconds goes very very fast
okay i shall go first you shall go first
okay okay ellen
name three things you do in a car uh you
drive you park
and you uh uh say hello to people
you do when you're waiting
when you're driving have you ever lived
in a small town you're raised here
all right all right okay let's see i see
now we need some like judges
or something you drive you you say hi
you wink you win
okay well you name three things you
should never do in the car
never uh uh drink uh
smoke make love that's not true
but you shouldn't do it i mean yeah you
should do it at home
i see it's hard it is hard it is hard
okay ellen tell us three words you use a
lot uh
love uh baby and uh
be kind i'm gonna give you that one
because that's the right answer yeah
okay we'll name your three favorite
songs to sing in the shower
in the shower uh the the the dream girls
uh
i'm telling you um whitney houston's
uh oh darn it yeah but that's uh it's
like the
end i am telling you
i'm not going
you're the best man i've ever known
[Applause]
i used to be able to eat whatever i want
and then in six weeks i could get in any
shape
i wanted to get into but that's not the
case
anymore we're we're around the 12 or 14
week
uh mandatory uh training to
to do anything but but i love it i enjoy
um i enjoy the discipline of it for me
working on on your body
is the beginning of everything you know
your mind starts to work better
you're the better husband a better
father a better friend and
life is just better when you
you know care for your body at the
highest level
[Music]
you know growing up my mother and father
and grandmother
demanded no less of me than to
represent the family every time i
stepped out in a way
that was helpful to others the city
gave him his start
he's worked hard and the city has worked
hard for him
knowing that this man is from west
philly opens eyes for them they that
opens their lands
when you're in philadelphia you see a
lot of things in the youth in the
neighborhood that
not always positive and i think seeing
that
will motivate you all in his own because
you're always going to want something
better for yourself you don't have
enough role models out here you got too
many kids being led astray
thinking the wrong things is what's good
they grow up too fast
you need people that's putting that out
there like you don't have to do this you
don't have to do that
it's so much easier being yourself
when you are a young kid and you're
walking to school
and you see images like this it makes
you aspire to want to be
that person right what he's done in his
life
have vibrated all y'all overseas to
touch you and touch people
yeah around the world but this right
here will affect people the main thing
you did let me tell you the main detail
yeah you got will's ears right this
man who is an icon is looking
at gla so my kids every day will see
this
image and know that you can be whatever
you want to be this is a man who grew up
in philadelphia went to overbrook high
school up the street
was a part of this world that he
now is looking at us and telling my
children
you can be whatever you want to be
that's it's just so powerful
if you're a kid here growing up now and
you see this every day
it can give you a real understanding
that this guy
is me you know he lived here he grew up
here
he had the same chances as me the same
possibilities as me
the same everything and
he's being painted on a wall because
he's
done something incredible with his life
we're about to
make history we're doing an ig
live to the international space station
oh yeah and see now that's the thing
look i'm doing it like that
everybody can't do an interview to the
international
space station in terms of like the the
simple
basics right so you on earth
people have to poop you're like it's
important to poop
on earth right so when you're up there
i see your microphone floating
i need to understand what you do with
that like how do you manage that
well are you sure you want to talk about
this problem because it is pretty
challenging
like to say you can have a good day in
the bathroom and you can have a really
bad day in the bathroom and you really
you hope for the good days
but bad days can be challenging on earth
we talk about the the
you know the mile high club as anyone
you know
attempted for research purposes
has anyone attempted you know the
process
of procreating the human species uh
in space all right well similar to the
last question i'll just say are you sure
we want to talk about this on the
interview
i'm just you know i i'm a man of the
people drew
i'm a man of the people and it's
important to me
to ask the questions that the people
want the answers to
i'll just say as far as i know i have no
knowledge of those tests being done
uh but i can imagine that that would
present some unique opportunities
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that question of the day
i want to know what is the single
greatest lesson you learned today from
will smith
let me know put it down in the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video you're still here watching i want
to celebrate you because believe nation
we don't just watch videos we
do something about it so that's you and
you commit you promise you're gonna take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you me and
jeff had come out with
our smash hit parents just don't
understand we made a bunch of money we
want a grammy
album with triple platinum i had
motorcycles and cars
i called the gucci store in atlanta and
i was like hey will y'all close it down
if i bring my friends
and i'm smiling but that's stupid we
released
our next album and it was like
a flop it was a tragedy it went like
double plastic i had spent
most of my money like all of i spent all
my money
and i didn't forget but
i didn't pay the irs in my mind i mean i
wasn't like
trying to avoid paying taxes i was just
like
oh damn they need their money the irs
took off took all that stuff
so i was like broke broke broke
being famous and broke is a
shitty combination because you're still
famous
and people recognize you but they
recognize you while you sit
next to them on the bus and the stuff
they ask you to sign
on a bus you know like oh can you sign
my baby
that's a sharpie i probably shouldn't
just write on the baby with that
oh you too big to sign my baby well no i
mean
you know so i signed it so i was like
laying around and my girlfriend was like
dude we're not doing this like you're
not just going to be laying around this
house all day you're going to go do
something
i was like what what i'm supposed to do
go where people
is is doing it where are people doing it
go to the arsenio hall show just go
stand around at the arsenio hall show
yes that's stupid
so i went to the art city hall show and
i met a dude named benny medina benny
medina is the
real life fresh prince of bel air except
he actually went from watts
to beverly hills same basic concept way
shorter distance i meet benny and he
pitches me the idea for this show and
i'm like you know i'm not an
actor i'm like cool and he said hey you
know i want you to meet quincy jones
quincy jones is producing with me
so i find myself at quincy's and there's
actors and artists and celebrities and
politicians like
everybody that quincy's out it's like
the wiz
without the costumes so benny walks me
in
and introduced me to quincy and hey q
what's up man he said hey man
you know i saw your music videos i love
i love what you're doing i love what
you're doing
tell me your rap name again they call me
the fresh prince all right good that's
what we're gonna call the show
and he handed me a screenplay for a
failed morris day pilot like i don't
have the time
so i need you to do this i need to go
ahead take a few minutes take 10 minutes
study the script and i'm gonna clear all
the stuff out the living room
and we're gonna have everybody sit down
in the living room we're gonna do an
audition
he had movers that could reset his
furniture i was like this dude is real
so it goes out tell everybody come on
come on come on and i was at aq hold up
man hold up
i'm not ready to do no audition and he's
like oh
all right all right uh well what you
need tell me what you need just set the
meeting
for a week and i could do it he said
yeah yeah you know brendan tardikov the
head of nbc is out there i'll get him to
schedule for next week and then you know
what's gonna happen
something's gonna come up and then he's
gonna have to reschedule oh yeah
yeah so three so three weeks from now we
can do it three weeks from now i say
yeah yeah three weeks from now be good
or you can take 10 minutes
right now and you can change your life
forever
i was like [ __ ] it then
yes give me 10 minutes i said yes and i
let it rip and i got to the end and
everybody's clapping
quincy looks at brandon tardikov the
head of nbc
did you like it and brandon said yeah
yeah i liked it because he says no did
you like it
and he's like yeah i liked it he's like
good you're his lawyer
draw me up something right now if you
want some fire motivation from les
brown check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i want you to look at something
right now
thank you some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you're already working on
and you have experienced
a lot of setbacks